a new documentary tells the real-life
story of twins one of whom lost his
memory after a motorcycle accident and
recognized no one except his twin
brother Alex Lewis was 18 when he woke
from a coma not even knowing his name he
relied on Marcus to help rebuild his
memories from scratch but what he didn't
realize was that Marcus had decided not
to remind him about a shocking family
secret let's take a look at a clip from
the Netflix documentary tell me who I am
if he hadn't learned who I was then he
would have been all around the world but
it wasn't alone the party had me I
started piecing things together
he would give me a photo
I will construct a memory around that a
life single privileged family normal
parents he painted an idyllic picture
but I was never questioning anything I
had no reason to doubt him
[Music]
well Alex and Marcus Lewis are the twins
who wrote the book that formed the basis
of that documentary and they are here
with me now hello to both Alex and
Marcus and I watched the documentary
yesterday and I have to say it is one of
the most harrowing and heartbreaking
pieces of television I have ever seen as
you take the viewers through your story
and the journey that you go on Alex
that's let's start at the beginning of
this story as it is you're 18 years old
you're out on your motorbike and you
have a horrific accident you're in a
coma then for three months yes what is
about sort of we never really know but
it's about three and a half weeks right
and when you wake from that coma I just
have nothing I have nothing at all I
just see my twin brother opposite me
that I'll immediately say his name so I
think I'm okay and then I see my mother
then comes up to the bed and I have no
idea who she is and she starts stressing
me out so I said turn to Marx and say
who's that lady he says don't you know
so that's your mother and that's when I
realized that actually something's not
right then Marcus is to me do you
actually know your own name I said no I
don't so that's how it started
so for you your mind is entirely blank
apart from ya aqus yeah and Alex then
relies on you completely Marcus to
rebuild those memories yeah so when he
woke up and I realized that he just knew
absolutely nothing at all and we had to
start from scratch so he had to learn
what hospital was what a bed was what
shoes are how to do shoe laces I had to
teach him everything about his house his
bedroom even his own even his girlfriend
I mean everything was gone so I was the
one that was kind of leading him through
that and helping him along the way
so as Marcus is saying you go home from
hospital you have no idea
know where you are okay in this in a car
with a strange woman to a strange house
and everything is new
but I've got a quote I mean I'm 18 years
old but I probably got a mental age of
six seven eight year old so I'm quite
low so I'm not asking many questions and
everything's very basic to start with
and so Marcus sees these questions come
to you you are everything mmm to Alex
and you have a decision to make about
the picture that you paint for him well
it it was a gradual thing so obviously
as his mental age grew over the couple
of weeks I would then he would be asking
you slightly more difficult questions
once we got past the basic stuff and it
wasn't until he started asking slightly
more difficult questions like you know
what our mum and dad like had to be
going on holidays things like that that
I had to start saying I wasn't kind of a
nice fat [ __ ] to making it happen saying
oh yeah you know we used to go on lots
of holidays we used to so I was I had to
make a conscious decision once I've gone
in too far to actually change the
narrative which I decided that I wanted
to do and because you have no memories
photographs become really important and
they start to form your image of what
your childhood was like with the help of
Marcus one photograph I think we've got
a view on a childhood holiday and a
Marcus Alex is joining the dots and
creating an innocent vision of what
childhood is like yeah and so I because
he I was asking me about holidays I
managed to find a holiday that we'd been
on with some friends cuz I didn't go on
family holidays and there was a picture
of us in the sand two young boys and so
I showed him the picture and said look
this was one of the family holidays our
stepfather mr. fake friends I said it
was a French holiday he then accepted
that that's what we did for our even
when we were young and then he moved on
to other questions so it was all part of
the narrative that I was feeding him to
give him a happy childhood
but I wasn't challenging him on more
difficult questions I just wanted simple
answers put in in memory bank filling
the jigsaw puzzle and move on because in
anybody else there would have been
potentially signs that would have raised
suspicions your living arrangements you
two lived in in an outbuilding yes we
lived we lived well it sounds quite
horrific but we did live in a very large
house but we lived in an outbuilding to
it the two of you together and you had
very limited access to the main house
yes you know we have very limited but
for us it was you know we call it the
shared it was a glorified shed and but
we had three we had a certain amount of
freedom to be in there so we can do what
we wanted in the way so we went in the
house itself
you're a relationship with your
stepfather was it was difficult yeah he
was quite some he was very difficult man
he was very strict man very very
Victorian sort of upbringing you stood
up when he walked in the room you called
him Sir you shook his hand you only went
into his quarters of the house when you
invited and you did what you were told
and with your mum you obviously didn't
know her when you came round from the
coma but you you grew to love her I did
and I only knew her for 12 years of my
life and so I did I was told to choose
my mother and I grew very fond of her
and I grew to love her because I had
told him nice things about her so he
knew that term that she was you know he
had to start to have a relationship with
her when your father your stepfather
died you thought things would start to
change in your life and that the rules
are very strict rules by which you were
governed would go and that didn't happen
didn't know I think I from what I
understood about the family it was
always about him and he was the one who
laid all the rules down it turned out it
wasn't and he actually got worse after
he died and I'm rather put more
stringent rules in no front door key
can't have this you can't have that you
have to tell us when you're coming in
when you're going and that was
surprising and and at any point were the
questions becoming more difficult yes
they got they got more and more
difficult and I had them the lies and
the story had to get more and more
creative so that became an issue for me
over the years and to the point where I
just stopped kind of you know I just
stopped you know we got as far as we
could get with and his mental aid to
come back up to her sort of normal age
so it just we just followed that
narrative through telling this
32 years old at which point your mother
dies then five years later yeah she dies
she had a brain tumor and she died quite
quickly and that was when everything
changed because I cried because I go now
into this to love this lady and nobody
else did
and that's restrained my brother had a
completely opposite reaction to me I
didn't expect that and that got me
thinking that something was wrong and
that was the start of my next journey so
it started at 18 and then the next
journey started at 32 and there
literally had to start again almost from
Ground Zero and so you started to clear
the house we started to clear the house
up she was off she was antique dealer
she was a hoarder
so there was you know it took took us a
year to to clear the house which was
quite an arduous job used to do it sort
of every weekend and as we were doing
this Marcus did you fear that some of
those secrets which you wish you had
kept from Alex would be revealed I I get
the back of my mind I was fearing that
but I was feeling them probably I
couldn't imagine that was anything in
the house that would kind of lead
towards it not realizing that you know
there was and and if you know if I'd
found all of that stuff before I
probably could have dealt with it when
it all happened you know him with us
both present yeah and there was in you
see in the documentary there was a
cupboard with in a cupboard a secret
cupboard it was locked away and you
opened it and found something coming
family yeah and that changed everything
we found this photograph of two naked
boys which was us aged about ten and I
had to been cut off and it was placed
singly in a drawer and then I started
getting very confused then I started
really asking questions about what's
going on here
and that's when that's when everything
flipped and then I went to see some
counselling tried to work out what was
going on and that's when I challenged
Marcus for the first time in my life I
went and challenged him and said is this
you know where we abused by our mother
or not it was a simple question and he
just nodded his head
there was no he just gave me the
recognition that this extraordinary
thing statement I was making was
actually true because I just didn't
believe it was and presumably you didn't
want no no no I couldn't believe it was
and I didn't know why I was asking the
question has just seemed too far-fetched
for this idyllic life that I had been
living and then when he nodded my world
changed in that instance and we both
remember that that second to this day
nothing was ever the same after that
Marcus when he asked you that question
what went through your head mass panic
I think panic and fear that the kind of
this story that I'd created over so many
years which had also allowed me to
forget and allowed me to be free so it
was a two-way thing in a way so that the
more I gave him a fantasy life I was
giving myself a fantasy life so I was
living quite any sort of normal life in
that sense and then when he came and
said to me you know that you know did
did our mother abused us and I had I had
nowhere else to go with a question like
that it was so fun to but I just nodded
and said yes but I was I had so much
fear inside me that I couldn't give him
anything more than that so it was just a
one-word answer and then I left it it
was a Pandora's box that had been opened
but that you wanted to slam it shut I
wanted to open it give him a one word
answer and slam it and bury it a ton of
concrete I just couldn't bear the
thought I didn't have the strength I
didn't have the will to deal with it so
I just hid and I was quiet and I was
silent let's have a little look had a
bit more from that documentary my from
day one painted a picture of a Norman
family but none of that was true
it was a fantasy that I was creating
them how could we have secrets we don't
have secrets
the one person that I absolutely trusted
has betrayed me I just cried cried the
date
[Music]
I have been lying for 20 years I like
Marcus less still with me and before we
went to the break we talked about the
moment that you discovered the truth
about your past that you had been abused
by your mother and as we saw in that
clip Alex just just talk us through how
you felt to learn that that had been
held from you it was emotional just
watching it just there just that clip
but it was just my whole world which
just was shattered in that one instant
and and I just poked out I mean I
couldn't work I couldn't do anything it
took me quite some time just to grab the
enormity of a story this big inside this
idyllic family that I lived in and my
mind was getting mapped with what's real
what isn't real my parents my parents is
what what what is anything true so it
was enormous section for me it was the
first time that we ever argued or you
got upset with each other so that took
some doing as well as twins he were
incredibly close you'd shared everything
and this is something you hadn't been
able to share with him yeah it's some I
mean twins they we work on a kind of
unique bond so you know normal siblings
we kind of referring to the normal
siblings have a a sort of a hundred
percent connection and twins have 110
percent and we operate in the ten
percent and we've always done that so we
always kind of think about things in the
same way do everything we work together
we've always done everything so when
this revelation happened we lost that we
lost not only the 10% we lost the
hundred percent we lost everything but
that didn't last for that long
Alex got over the initial bit within a
month I think he was angry with me
really quite strongly for at least a
month and then we slowly got it back
together so we managed to get a hundred
cent back together but we never achieved
to get the ten percent that we were
missing as identical twins and and and
you said you'd replied just by nodding
and then silence did you at that point
talk anymore no I gave him I felt you
know he asked me a question I gave him
an answer which was a nod and yes our
mother abused us and then I think for
the next 20 odd years I didn't I didn't
give him any more information because I
wasn't capable of giving it to him it
was just too painful for me and I wanted
to just run back into my shell and be
silent and quiet so it was a you know
when I look back on it now I really we
should have just sat down and have a
chat but we didn't do that because I
think abuse and child abuse is such a
strong thing in everybody and and and I
was carrying it for both of us so I was
caring all my pain and all his pain and
it was just too much for me to cope with
so I just I just went more quiet in the
final part of the documentary we see you
coming together sitting down together
and confronting the truth about your
past what was that like for you Alex
took to get answers to the questions you
had for the first time but also to hear
things that presumably you never wanted
well it was quite scary
because I kind of knew what was coming
because beautifully written a book so
five years before and where he had
indicated most of that stuff but I'd
actually rebuilt that back up as a
monster in my head because I only had
tip bits and it was a bit ambiguous it
was quite ambiguous and the way it been
written down and the way I had it but
what I really wanted more than anything
was just have my twin tell me directly
himself why he had what his feelings
were and what really happened so I
actually wanted to make it smaller so it
wasn't such a great shock when he told
me but it was an enormous release that I
finally had and that's what actually all
I wonder wanted was him to just sit down
and tell me which didn't take very long
and for you to sit down and and tell
Alex was that as alex describes it a
release or for you did it mean you had
to relive at all no yeah it was a was a
release I mean we started making the
documentary and this then it then became
not about the documentary it just became
about us because I suddenly realized we
had an opportunity which we hadn't
really
foxie or explored it can form a
therapist ozone is a form of sarin it
wasn't really the last day of the shoot
when we were sitting in the studio that
we stripped out the cameras and
everything else and it was just us
talking and it suddenly remember for the
first time sitting opposite each other
having a grown-up conversation man at
which we should have done you know 20
years before when it was really quite
sort of it's just really silly that with
you know we're both so close but we did
finally get the closure that we were
after and it was amazing it was a split
second right at the end where we got our
10% back which has been incredible for
us looking back Marcus would you change
anything about the way in which you
dealt with this question I think I think
looking back on it now and doing what
we've done and speaking to people we've
spoken about and finding the reaction
that we've had to that to the movie I
think I shouldn't I would have if I'd
had the courage I would have spoken 20
years before and not for him through all
the anguish for 20 years
but you still would have painted this
picture still I would have given him
what we what I call a free pass so he
had you know many blissful years
I didn't mean to three powers that he
didn't need to know and that for me was
a gift and there was a free pass and he
had yes it was a lie yes it was made up
yes it was very upsetting for him to
understand that but I think that you
know for me I would I would never change
that I would do that in a heartbeat
again I have you through the course of
this Alex put yourself in Marcus's shoes
and asked yourself what what you would
have done no I think if I'd had the
strength which I don't think I would
have had a being as good as him and I
would have liked to think that I would
have done the same to protect him yeah I
I didn't notice till that moment in the
movie that I did had never really taken
on board the amount of of anguish that
he'd hit he was doing I did I never
really appreciated what he'd done for me
until then it was a real light bulb
moment he never realized what I wanted
and I never realized what he'd given
it's amazing really that we just never
did it until that moment and and tell me
now having confronted this together
what life is like for you I'd sort of
say from that moment on we've done I
mean we went we met each other
afterwards we walked outside we just
looked at each other and we said are we
good and we said yeah we're good and we
went home and we've never spoken about
it since and probably never will so for
us the story is over that we both them I
see that we both have lives
we're both happily married we both have
two kids who are both about the same age
your families are very close to
everything that's still working our
businesses together so life is looking
much more simple simple now yeah yeah to
have done this as you describe markers
so powerfully it almost became not about
the documentary this was just about the
two of you but so then see it on the
screen and to have other people watching
your story for the first time how does
that feel well it's it's an added bonus
I mean we hadn't realized how big it
wasn't gonna get we didn't realize the
power that the documentary was gonna
have on people and you know having done
sort of film festivals and have people
coming up and telling us their stories
people telling us stuff that they've
never told anybody in their lives you
suddenly realized that actually people
just need to talk and and what we've
really learned is that being silent is
not you know you just we just got to
break the silence we've all got to have
a conversation and we want people to
engage in a conversation and maybe watch
the documentary go for a dinner party
have a conversation with a friend and
they tell you that they were abused and
you just have a conversation about it
and it's been an absolute privilege to
meet you Alex and Marcus Lewis thank you
very much indeed thank you thank you
thanks having son